maintenant bien vous savez on les élève
au québec vont reprendre le chemin de
l'école
oui l'automne s'annonce mouvementée pour
les commissions scolaires
je retrouve à québec et d'ailleurs à ce
sujet là alain fortier président de la
fédération des commissions scolaires du
québec
bonjour monsieur fortier à la question
tout d'abord en qui touche les enfants
et leurs parents parlent tellement de
pénurie d'enseignants ces dernières
semaines à quoi ça ressemble
concrètement au fait c'est sympa ce que
vous lisez partout dans les journaux est
ce que vous interdis d'avis dans les
bulletins de nouvelles
ça ressemble à une restriction sera
difficile mais pour lequel je pense que
les commissions scolaires réussi vont
encore une fois à s'assurer que rôle
d'adjoint signifiant pour s'occuper des
enfants et leur faire l'école comme on
souhaite que l'école soit fait à
l'adulte signifiant qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par là parce que dans la
dernière année on a vu certaines classes
où les enseignants passent elles à
quelques journées seulement et ensuite
on change et d'adultes
est ce que tous les enfants auront un
titulaire de classe à votre avis cette
fois ci oui un autre à mon avis oui bien
sûr qu'il ya des classes de francisation
ou à la fête ils dépendent demain sur
nouveau no1 gros l'offre va s'assurer
que si on d'essayer de l'ouvrir il y
avait une personne pour pour enseigner à
ces élèves là qui veulent apprendre le
français chez nous mais ça veut dire
aussi dans les services de garde et
moment où ils sont vous savez des
services de garde c'est toujours des
endroits où c'est un peu plus difficile
de trouver des employés parce que les
heures de travail sont coupées un peu le
matin le midi le soir mais rien en début
là donc ça fait en sorte que là aussi
quand je parle de jean signifiant ça
prend des gens dans les services de
garde lorsque il n'ya pas de classe mais
qu'ils enfants demeurent à l'école très
bien qu'une ouverture des classes pour
les tout petits les maternelles quatre
ans à vous construire un 4 5 1 des
moteurs
bien sûr parce que vous savez de le
nombre d'enfants à ma place devrait être
aux alentours de 17 à ses 5 îles
la norme ont entre 14 et 17 là dans la
moyenne des classes sont de aux élèves à
ces souris
c'est dans les journaux des endroits où
les classes sont plaints des endroits où
il ya six élèves
donc vous savez quand on ajoute de gay
scolaire dans un moment de pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre ça accentue la pression
sur le service des ressources humaines
pour s'assurer qu'il ya quelqu'un qui va
enseigner dans ces classes l'eau mais
allez vous y arrivez pour les classes
qu'on ouvre réellement est ce que vous y
arrivez là pour septembre
oui on les commissions scolaires font
toujours le travail des fois c'est à la
dernière minute ont réussi mais celui ce
qui m'inquiète aussi un peu s'est pas
nécessairement la rentrée scolaire mais
une faute l'année commençait bien le
phénomène des ressources humaines
normales se produisent à eux car ils
sont malades et des gens qui deviennent
ans un congé de paternité et là ce sont
les suppléances qui commence à être
difficile à combler est donc tout au
long de l'année là la question des
ressources humaines demeurent entre le
1er septembre ils veulent que tu veux
mais de votre côté à la fédération on
est comme ça on se colère vous commencé
l'année sans trop savoir de quelle façon
vous allez la terminer parce que il ya
ce projet de loi qui sera présenté par
le gouvernement legault probablement cet
automne peut-être même en septembre pour
abolir transformer les commissions
scolaires en centres de service
est ce que vous comptez vous adresser
aux tribunaux comme prévoit le fallait
comme son scolaire anglophone de payer
certains que nous allons faire ce que
nous devons faire mais pour le moment
nous venons de lancer une campagne sur
les réseaux sociaux pour démontrer à la
population l'utilité des élus scolaires
dans leurs quartiers dans leur
communauté
la campagne s'appelle l'éducation au
coeur de nos actions et moi j'invite
vraiment toute la population ali sur
facebook et à voir ses vidéos qui
démonte commun les bus scolaires fait la
différence dans son quartier dans sa
communauté
parce que si le gouvernement s'apprête à
enlever un droit citoyen il est de notre
devoir d'informer les citoyens de ce
qu'on est en train de le relever ça peut
vraiment ici on voit d'ailleurs l'une de
ces vidéos vous avez lancé dans l'un de
ces campagnes de sensibilisation
monsieur fortier mais ça fait des
décennies
existe les commissions scolaires au
québec comment se fait-il que vous avez
besoin de sensibiliser les gens les
parents à l'importance des élus
scolaires
les gens ne vont pas voter aux élections
scolaires vous le savez si on se met à g
et sur la base d'un taux bas on pourrait
dire que c'est la fin du français au
québec on te dit qu'il faut deux pour sa
de francophones hors-québec l'on
s'habille l'autre la différence entre
tous est un droit
il m'apparaît en tout cas qu'il ya eu
une énorme différence sur votre question
qui est pour mes prestations quand même
monsieur fortier normalement elle c'est
un indicateur important
oui vous avez raison mais en même temps
est-ce que si la démocratie un petit peu
de difficultés pourquoi ne devrait-on
pas s'unir tout le monde et faire en
sorte qu'elle prend un nouveau sauf
prenons par exemple le municipal le
provincial et le fédéral un tout les
tous les paliers de démocratie au canada
où sont en retrait de diminuer en termes
de participation et moi je pense que la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement s'est
mobilisé ses citoyens autour de ces
institutions
bien plus que le contraire des
démobilisés en leur disant si vous
n'avez pas d'enfants à l'école rester de
chez vous pour moi de ce fait aucun sens
et je reviens en terminant avec ma
question monsieur fortier vous avez dit
on va faire ce qu'il faut faire mais ce
que en bout de ligne vous allez vous
vous adressez aux tribunaux pour la
survie des comme ça scolaire c'est
difficile de prévoir jusqu'où va se
rendre des intentions du gouvernement je
sais que mes collègues anglophones ont
une emprise extrêmement solide autour de
l'article 23 de la charte canadienne qui
leur donne le droit de gouverner leurs
institutions vous et donc les
anglophones heroes de ce côté là alors
produite et oui nous verrons ce que des
francophones nous ferons très bien alain
fortier merci d'avoir été avec nous
depuis bonne vanne rentrée scolaire
cette semaine dans les prochains jours
merci merci d'avoir évité bon dimanche
en vain